le jour où ils égalent tu prends un
ticket un kama la sécu et attend motifs
derrière
garé mon âge il ya un
mois mais c'est pas parce que tu y
arrives pas que moi je vais pas y
arriver moi je vais réussir
[Applaudissements]
tous les animateurs
à genève le mien je me tape le dire
et après il alors la pression le foutoir
ballon est tout à fait
évident de choisir à oisy demande alors
à choisir je ne veux pas avoir de
pouvoir
de la caisse qui se passe mais on à
bonnes questions on n'a pas les épaules
c'est la bonne route et chic alors mais
c'est incroyable alors on a laissé ses
couilles dans sa loge
et franchement je serais pas voter tu
peux me redescendre mais
pas dans le frigo
non non pas dans le frigo n'ont pas cédé
et dammam et
[Rires]
la prise de poids donc c'est vraiment de
style assez vrai lance en effet deviez
choisir qui oui mais alors mais alors je
vais vous dire à ma le choix ya jamais g
ou dire je vais arrêter je préfère
mourir
oui parce que je n'ai connaître au
bahreïn que tu connais ça c'est ça ou ta
famille proche meurt doit choisir lequel
des choisi la jetée des regrettés ou
choix est vite fait thomas famille athée
sont là
il y aurait tout
vraiment
je le dis en toute liberté
cyril là tu sais trop imaginons juste un
baiser
non mais ça n'est pas engageant syrie
turquie suis heureuse moi tu préfères
rookie profile préfères tu préfères quoi
tu préfère rouler une pelle un match de
leur mandat urgo voilà non mais on
t'embrasse chacun est une île lequel
lequel cette démo qu'elle va toucher de
plus
[Applaudissements]
tafer toit ce qui est un peu me coucher
avec giulia
j'ose dire franchement je propose
également vous embrasser tous les noms
déjà fait avec la langue on joue on
s'est vu notre futur et ont apporté
beaucoup c'est simple ça c'était dans
tes d'intérêt patois
mémoire ouais alors que je vous dire la
vérité je te connais tu es je connais
vous si vous vous embrasser de le faire
on va le faire et bien ce sera la pub
alors je vais te dire déjà l'argent moi
sa part été gens parce que je suis
arrivé il vous plait et oui s'il vous
plaît vous êtes à vent se calme mais
naim tu vas chercher cet aventurier
sais je sais pas parce que ta monture
hier tu as ta bouffe et lui parler
ça va
passer quand même fait des héros alors
alors bon alors ouais mais c'était que
nous arrête avec ça n'arrivera jamais
c'est vrai c'est vrai que vous avez une
planète
j'avais un très beau cul
c'est leur train de briller toi non mais
jouer les limougeauds glitter dans 48
ans ya peu un hétéro dans ça
c'est clair on abandonne la japonaise
jamais abandonné parce que vous perdez
votre temps c'est vrai je voulais la
vérité tu sais pas si petite allumeuse
alors s il te plaît ne parle pas comme
ça non
c'est une lenteur toile à
l'énorme un peu plus rien mais qu'est ce
que tu es sur deux
courriers soit le koh lanta du cul
ouais c'est passer deux heures sur ton
poteau
[Applaudissements]
avec moi ça fait qu'avec sa classe avec
moi je vais terminer jusqu'en chine toi
moi c'est à pékin express et qu'on va
mener jusqu'en chine
soit pas capable dans la gueule des gens
alors riche et varié en syrie jordanie
va stopper ça parce que je vous lis pas
perdre votre temps mais je tiens
aujourd'hui jolie elle avait lavé ses
roches ou alors mon slip est fermé aux
lol non mais la part d'un baiser pas du
petit chien
éliminé tout seul moi je suis abonnée
baiser moi j'adore les bonnes abbaye du
tout c'est révocable un poêle à bois
voilà bah parce que sinon eh bah
maintenant à la barbe pousse - là bas
[Rires]
bush mais bac donc dans mon petit c'est
vrai at a gagné mathieu tu as gagné avec
j'ai gagné à gagner évident par tous
n'est pas distant de muscles avec la
réforme allez bisous
c'est bien franchement incombe tout ça
remerciements je sais ce que c'est avec
le public lui donne ça il te met ça
[Rires]
à
[Applaudissements]
ça fait bien plaisir de rappeler une
fois de plus que je suis hétéro voilà
merci et je le resterai et c'est vrai à
ceux ci l'a fait que tel rap et de tous
les jours tu pense pas qu'ils aient un
problème non parce que justement avec
des énergumènes comme mousse en tout cas
on a eu une révélation pendant cette
émission c'est qu'il a un ça y est qui a
choisi de conduire à gauche ou à droite
serré
ça y est lui c'est au contraire
aujourd'hui voilà d'accord il sera au
à 10h45 bien entendu et si manger une
saucisse ce sera bien sûr pas au top